they try their best to offer reassurance
but for the carers of these elderly
people it's not
easy they've just been forced
out of their flooded care home their
faces
etched with confusion and concern
how are you feeling i feel
very bad
i meet johannes giessen in the last year
he's had to deal with the pandemic
a stroke and now the worst floods of his
lifetime
he told me the floods were a huge
surprise it came so quickly
and then they said everyone must leave
and the evacuation
started sheltering now from the sun
rather than the biblical rain they
witnessed the residents wait
their turn for an ambulance to move them
to temporary accommodation
with such great care they're gently
helped along on a journey they would
give anything
not to have to take this must be
incredibly tough and difficult for these
elderly people
yeah yes very
it brings up memories of wartime where
they could only take along what they
could get hold of
their clothes their shoes and what they
were wearing
and now they had to leave their homes
again that was for many of them
very difficult finally it's johannes's
turn
he puts on a brave face
best of luck all right stay safe best of
luck
and with that he's gone just one story
amongst many
just one of the countless number of
lives here
that have been turned upside down
jonathan samuels
sky news earthstar in germany